This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown. My mind was blown.
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spake, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for
our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're talking about a relationship style, relationship dynamic that many of you are probably familiar with, either through name or through experience. You may not have the words to describe it. I know when I first heard about it, I didn't, but it's called the Pursuer Distancer Dynamic. If you have ever been in a situation where the moment you feel yourself getting close to somebody or closer to someone, they pull away, or where you're constantly wanting more from somebody, asking somebody to meet your emotional needs, and they just
feel incapable of it, or they tell you that they feel suffocated by you, or or that you are too much that they need space, you have likely experienced this dynamic as a pursuer. Alternatively, if you have ever been in a relationship, been in a situation where you genuinely feel a little bit overwhelmed and you feel like you really need time, you really need space, you really need distance to yourself in a relationship,
you really feel pressured by somebody, maybe even getting the ick from their affection, even though you really like them, you maybe experienced this dynamic as the distancer. In very, very simple terms, the pursuer distancer dynamic involves one person seeking a deeper connection whilst the other person resists it for whatever reason. And this creates a very frustrating cycle where one person tries to get closer to the other, person to fulfill their own unique emotional needs, which causes the other person to withdraw to protect their needs to compensate for that space then. The pursuer tries harder to get even
closer. The distance that pulls away even further and you kind of see the situation and the cycle that we end up in. And it ultimately continues and ultimately both people end up pretty unhappy and pretty hurt. I've had so many requests for episodes which discuss dynamics like this, especially for people in their 20s who are kind of encountering this for the first time and thinking, like, what's wrong with me? Or like, why can't I get close to somebody? Why don't people love me back? Why do I find love so hard? Nothing is wrong with you. Whichever role you keep falling into, this dynamic is just really complicated. It is formed by so many things we often have, very little control over and very little awareness over from neurobiology to attachment style
to our nervous system, even to our child psychology. And so that is what we are going to explore today. What is this dynamic? Why do people find themselves in this dynamic? Can you get out of it? Is there something that either person can do to fix a relationship that has fallen into this rut and what does that look like. So that's what we're going to touch on today. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind the pursuer, distancer, relationship dynamic.
On the surface, the pursuer distancer dynamic, I think seems very intuitive, right? There's generally one person who wants more, one person who wants less. The person who wants more, the pursuer, the person who wants less is the distancer. I feel like we already kind of went through this, but just as a reminder.
The pursuer typically, It's not that just they want more of everything. What they really want more of is connection and intimacy and reassurance. And they want to fight through their fights. They want to know that everything's okay. They want to know why somebody's angry with them. They want to work it out in the moment. They want to know they're loved.
They want more date nights. They want maybe more sex. They don't want enmeshment. They just want very deep intimacy. and that is a core need for them. In contrast, the distance are, it's not that they don't want that. It's just that it's a little bit harder for them. They prefer their alone time.
They need their space. They like to process things independently. They value quality time over the quantity of time. They don't like feeling smothered. Sometimes they push the other person away, not because they don't love them, not because they're not interested, but just because it is too much. and that can come off as really, really dismissive. Of course it's going to.
It's going to come off as if this person doesn't want to be with you. It's not always like that, but I think this is like the general profile of each role. That's typically what it would appear like from the outside. It's also worth noting this doesn't just happen in romantic relationships, but in friendships as well. Even sometimes with parents. One friend, for example, really wants more, more of everything. more one-on-one-time, more invitations, more of a connection,
and the other person is maybe fearful of being engulfed by that friendship, fearful of becoming too dependent on that one person, fearful of being hurt. Again, like I said, it may also happen with parenting, where a parent can feel really uneasy by this idea that their whole identity is going to become that of a mom or that of a dad. so they push their child to be independent so that they can be as well. That is a whole other episode. It's a lot less common, maybe more common actually. It's really actually the root of a lot of attachment pain. But yeah, the pursuer distance of dynamic gets a big hype in relationships
and when you start looking for you kind of see it everywhere. The thing is, it's not wholly unhealthy, right? In itself, it's not that terrible. Maybe people are going to be mad at me for saying that, but every relationship will have some aspect of distancing and pursuing in it. Dare I say it's healthy to have that chase for both people to occasionally play each role in a fight, to show the other person they care about them, or even when it comes to intimacy, right, to feel needed, to also feel a little bit needy. There have been a lot of relationship therapists who would say that the push and pull on that level keeps a spark alive. However, when A, both people always play the same role all the time,
B, both people feel frustrated by the other's reaction, and C, they can't talk about it, they can't see the other person's perspective, they're not willing to change, that is where we have the unhealthy pursuer-distance dynamic. Nobody is happy. And the thing is, is that each person is also constantly triggered by the other person because there is so much like natural friction leading to this impasse. In this situation where one person wants more and one person wants less, I think the real issue is like who should have to compromise? Like who whose way wins? Who has to receive less or more or a different amount of the behavior that they want, that they want? So there was this source at the Gottman Institute.
which is one of the world's biggest research labs on love and dating. And this person basically says that this dynamic is one of the main reasons that couples fall out of love. They researched thousands of couples on this pursue a distance of dynamic. And they discovered that when people get stuck in this dynamic, whether they are, I don't know, 19, 27, 49, whatever it is, they have more than an 80% chance of breaking up or divorcing in the next four to five years. Those aren't good odds. So we really do need to understand what's actually going on below the surface. What's happening in each person's mind?
Let's actually start with the distancer in this dynamic. There is this wonderful man. His name is Augustus Napier. I think that's how you pronounce it. And he is a pioneer in the field of family therapy. He's worked with hundreds of couples on this. In his research, he observed that when someone engages in strong distancing behavior, what they are really motivated by is fear, fear of being engulfed in a relationship, fear of losing a sense of
self. And a big part of that is social conditioning. You know, this idea that they don't need anyone. You know, this applies to all genders, but sometimes with men as well, it's because they're scared of being too reliant. They've been taught that they shouldn't be that way. In general, it's this fear of being so attached that if the other person was to leave, if the other person was to disappear, what would they do? Who would they be without that person? That's a strong reason why the distancer is the way they is. You can also just see how much of this comes down to past experience.
Yes, in childhood with parents, as somebody who wanted unconditional love, from a parent, from a caregiver, and realizing that wasn't on offer. realizing that you could only ever rely on yourself, but also from early romantic relationships, even friendships, where at some stage, the distances has thought, this person is amazing, this person is the one, I'll give them everything, I'll show them how invested I am, and it didn't end well. They left. They found a new best friend. They didn't love them back in the same way. and our minds, our bodies hold on to that. They store it in a very deep and dark place.
And they then change, our body, our mind then changes all of our future behaviors to avoid that ever happening again at all costs. We don't want to live through that hurt. We don't want to be disappointed in somebody else again. And the best way to ensure that is to just hold everyone at arm's length. is just to make sure that there is always something just for you, something they don't know about, a past, a memory, a hobby, a friendship that you can escape into should you feel overwhelmed, should things be going pear-shaped?
To them, it's safety. It's insurance, but to the pursuer that looks like secrets, it looks like distance, it looks like an unwillingness to try and open up. It may also come down to simply how they learnt to self-reaching. regulate. I think I just mentioned it, but, you know, a big part of being a disinsurer as personal history is that they obviously learned that they needed to take care of their own emotions and their own problems. There is a great deal of overlap here with hyper-independence and emotional avoidance and only needing to rely on themselves. And this isn't always because their parents or their
family were neglectful or something went wrong. It's simply that at some stage in their life, they've encountered stress, they've encountered something that was very heavy, maybe not traumatic, just very heavy, and they realized that if they could just deal with it themselves, maybe that was more effective. They didn't need to be let down. Maybe there wasn't somebody there available to help them. They didn't want to be a burden, especially, I think, with guys, right? Big emotions. Maybe they did have a chance to express them once, and it wasn't taken well. So now it's that idea, that approaches off the table. Essentially what they realized was that when something bad happens, if they go away and if they self-isolate and if they rationalize a problem enough, it will be
solved. And they won't have to rely on somebody else's assistance. And maybe they won't have to be burdened by somebody else's emotional problems at time as well. You know, it just feels a lot more freer that they just have themselves. So that is the emotional blueprint they follow. this is the wound they're entering with. And the pursuer is entering with what seems like a very different wound, but is actually probably the same one. That same researcher, Napier, here observed in similar research that when looking at pursuing behavior, this individual is often motivated by a fear of rejection, a fear of being left alone. So they seek frequent intense connection to soothe that fear. For them, they maybe actually went through some of the very same experiences as the
distancer of being left, of being hurt, of feeling unseen, but their reaction to it has been to go deeper, to not leave any gap between them and the other person for distance to occur. Part of pursuing behavior is emotional monitoring, right? Constantly being like, hey, are you okay? Are you mad at me? Can we talk about that? Like, what's going on? Wanting to keep tabs on how our relationship is going. That's probably very healthy. But then sometimes it getting to a point of like constant reassurance seeking, constantly needing to know every second of the other person's emotions so that there is no opportunity to be blindsided. How do you prevent yourself from being blindsided from being left is making sure that every single emotion is visible at every
single time. Every single issue that could come up, like you were aware of it, a hundred kilometers down the road. That's why a big part of pursuers' behavior is yes. Doing the emotional labor of the relationship, doing the relationship maintenance, bringing up problems because they want a future with this person, but also because maybe a part of them is like, this way I kind of get inside it into if something's going to blow up in my face. And that can sometimes develop into, yeah, again, a compulsion or a very intense behavior
for the distancer, not an intense behavior on itself, but an intense behavior for the distancer of like, why are you always in my business? Why do you always want so much from me? And it's not that this person or any person in the situation is broken or has done anything wrong. It's just how they are responding to the prospect of being hurt. and to the prospect of social pain. Some of you may be asking, if the wound is maybe similar, what makes one person go one way and somebody go the other? What makes somebody a distancer and somebody makes somebody a pursuer?
Again, yeah, a bit of it comes down to past experiences, a bit of it comes down to socialization. I feel like we could say a lot more men are probably going to be distances than women, not that it's an exclusive thing, but majorly it's nervous system regulation yet again. From a regulation standpoint, these patterns often map onto different stress responses. Distances often lean towards a deactivating strategy. So when stress rises, their nervous system says, like, reduce intensity, pull back, self-soothe alone,
and pursuers lean towards what we call a hyper-activating strategy. So when stress rises, their system says, get your hands dirty, increase proximity, seek reassurance, problem self here. Close the distance gap between you and the other person. Again, both people are trying to manage the same underlying fear. I don't want to feel that original wound again. I don't want to be hurt again. They're just doing it in a different way that when these two people find each other actually makes it worse for both people. There is this famous idea in like Carl Jung's work of like the container and the contained. And essentially what he says is that When you look at anybody, we're all going to lean slightly towards one of these two styles or systems.
Are you going to be the container or the distancer who finds emotional security within the self, or the contained, the pursuer, who finds security in the relationship? And I think with this, we can more clearly see the dance that's going on here. One step in, one step back. Actually, both people are always moving kind of in synchronicity just in opposite directions. never touching, never close enough for one person, too close for the other. So the question we may all be asking at this point, I know I've certainly asked this, is why do people stay? And why do these two kinds of people find each other so often? If from our point of view, it looks like they just shouldn't
work out. Why is this relationship dynamic so common? Well, that is what we are going to reveal after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter,
and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex
pseudoscience that doesn't dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see
there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really?
Yeah for me It's one of the most important years For black people In American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The key thing to know, neither person in this relationship is wrong. Nobody is the problem. Nobody is the bad guy. I think distances get a bad rap as like the damaged one. But that's not true. Both people have wounds the same way that we all have, we all have baggage that we bring into a relationship and we throw all over the floor and we have to figure out which items are ours and which items are the other persons. The thing is, if a distance are dated, another distance, it would probably be okay. And if a pursuer dated another pursuer, it would probably be smooth the sailing. It's not to say those relationships aren't going to have issues, but it's not the individuals
that are the problem. It's the friction that has caused. Distances and pursuers find each other a lot because of the challenge the other person presents, but also because of this desire to kind of fit into each other's lives. They kind of both want a little bit of what the other person has. the ability to get truly close to somebody for the distancer and the ability to be a little bit more mysterious and elusive for the pursuer. It's intoxicating. It's like this yin and yang situation where they both are kind of seeking something that
they're not. The other thing is that at different times during the pursuit distance cycle, each person is briefly going to get what they want. And that is the intoxicating thing. At some stage, right, in this whole cycle, the pursuer is going to get really up. upset and they're going to pull all the way back. And they're going to revert to the silent treatment. They're going to use tools they haven't thought to use yet. They're going to be
exhausted. They're going to be like, fine, I'm going to go. I'm going to give you all the distance. And in doing this, they actually give the distance to exactly what they want. And the distance to finally feels calm enough, regulated enough, able to process things enough, so they come back. And ironically, now the pursuer gets what they want. It's like, how? finally this person is here again. The intimacy is back. The chance to repair and heal is here. And the thing is is that this looks like forward movement. It looks like healing. It looks like you've discovered the secret to getting the distance are closer and the distance discovered the secret to getting the pursuer to move further away. It is literally just the same
desperate pattern in a new form. When this happens, very briefly, both people switch roles, right, for a short period of time. this makes self-identification as the pursuer or distancer really a lot harder and very confusing because if both people are at sometimes like very small amounts of times playing the other role surely we're surely it's not an issue but the opposite role doesn't come naturally again this is temporary this is a small switch this is a symptom of the cycle continuing both people get so worked up that they briefly become the other person. So what is the long-term damage happening here? And how do these relationships often end? Therapists talk about this point
in a relationship like this where the person who has always been the emotional seeker, the one who wants closeness, who spurs on those deep conversations, they just become silent. They become what we call a burnt-out pursuer. They basically just stop reacting altogether. again, as we were describing, this situation of just like, my hands are up in the air, I don't know what to do, I don't know how to get you closer to me, so I'm just going to give up. And yeah, therapists talk about this moment, and they say, like, this is when I get scared. This is when it looks like the relationship is probably going to break apart for good. And the thing is, is that it may look like it comes all at once, but if you are the pursuer,
you've probably been running this race for a long time. There have been so many rounds of the same cycle of pulling back, them stepping forward, there's a temporary closeness, it all looks great, optimistic, and then things slowly return to the way they are. You have probably had so many times of being like, all I want is for you to say that you love me. All I want is for you to say is to work on a problem with me. All I want is for you to remember the small things, to want to fix things in our relationship. And the emotional load just becomes too heavy. And then again, when it gets to this point, there is no coming back.
this other person has sacrificed their needs for too long. The distancer might also have a moment like this where they just feel so tired, so unnatural by trying to change for this other person that they just jump ship. They panic. They don't just become the distance or they become the flea. They just can't do it anymore. The mismatch becomes too evident. And people are left hurt, people are left frustrated and sad
in that they gave so many months or years trying to compromise. and you might look at that and think, what did they expect? And the thing is, though, this isn't the only outcome. You might think this is always going to be how pursue a distance and relationships, how the course goes, but there is actually things that people can do to break out of this. That's the good news in this. This is the worst case scenario, but our brain's malleable, their neuroplastic, even into old age, given the right conditions, if you were in this situation right now,
you can adapt your brain to form new synaptic connections, to replace old relationship patterns with healthy ones, to find a new way of bonding and caring and being with somebody else if you want to change. Even if you recognize yourself in what we are speaking about today, there's nothing to say that it is all doom and gloom. Because the core thing here is, if you can relate, you are self-aware. You can see the cycle taking place. And if your partner can also see the cycle taking place as well, your chances are so much better. That self-awareness is like the most critical thing I think I've learned from, you know, so many years of just reading the research. But it does take a lot of compromise from both people to mend and to bring, like both
people have to want to be at the table. And I think the hard thing is that sometimes the distance it doesn't want to be. They want things to be okay between each other, but the emotional debt of having to try is just too much for them. So if you do want to work through this, you really just have to start with self-compassion. If you're trapped in this cycle, being angry of self, being frustrated, being like, what do I expect? Like, this is never going to work out. Isn't going to help you. You need to allow yourself space to feel composed, to feel clear about what you want, and to be able to regulate your nervous system again, not in the way that you have been doing, which is to either seek an artificial level of closeness or seek an artificial level of distance.
Perhaps you are in the cycle because of the reasons that we've spoken about because of psychological childhood wounds. Acknowledge this, give yourself grace, and really ask yourself, you know, if I had a choice, I probably wouldn't choose this. That means that it's probably not my fault. that doesn't give you an excuse to then treat somebody in a way that doesn't feel kind or to be like, or to keep hurting yourself even, but it may also, and definitely will just give you some kindness and provide an explanation for why you are the way you are instead of just because I'm a bad person
or because I don't deserve love. Secondly, you need to have that compassion for the other person. You need to realize that the same way you have wounds, they have wounds as well. It's just that they are acting out their own subconscious unconscious processes in a different way. They are looking for the intimacy that they lack in a different way, just different to you. You are both trying to feel whole again through this relationship and to feel loved. And equally, you're hurting each other, but that's not the way it has to be. Basically, like, you need to step into their shoes and be like, essentially, why would I be the way that I am? Let's swap positions here.
Why would I continue a cycle like this? Why would I always put distance? Why would I always need more closeness? Can you have empathy for the other person's position? If you can, I think that's like amazing progress. I think then each person needs to integrate the part they're struggling with, and they need to be committed to change. Here is the hurdle.
Here is the deal breaker. Especially if you are a pursuer right now, listen up. you're the only one putting an effort here, if they just keep making excuses, this isn't about being a pursuer, this isn't about being a distancer, this is about respect. And at this point, it's about whether or not they care about you. Obviously, labeling our behavior matters, but when it becomes a shield of like, well, you know, I just didn't reply to your message for three days because I'm a distancer. I forgot your birthday because I'm a distancer. Or alternatively, like, no, I went through your phone because I'm a pursuer. That's not about labels. It's about respect and it's not
respect and it's not healthy and it's not about empathy for the other person or for ourselves. It's an excuse. Be honest. With yourself and with the other person and altogether, are you guys capable of change? Is this person you are with capable of change that they've given any evidence for it? And are they showing you movement that isn't just the same cycle? or are they showing shortcuts? For the anxious person, you need to genuinely learn to self-sooved. You need to learn that you are actually super capable
of taking a beat, of taking care of yourself, of reassurance, of seeking safety inside of you. And for the avoidant, I think there needs to be this like test period, this period of like, I'm just going to see how I,
what happens when I take the risk and I talk about my problems. I've never done it before or it's ended badly before. If I'm going to lose this person, what else do I have to risk? I'm going to try. I'm going to tell them I had a terrible day at work. I'm going to tell them that I'm struggling mentally. I'm just going to test how it would feel to be open about that.
And I'm going to trust as much as I can in my whole body, I'm going to trust that this person isn't going to let me down. And it's going to hold me emotionally in a way that I probably have always wanted to be held. Both of you then need to do the hardest thing in situations like this, which is realize that you could get hurt. That is a possibility here.
Throughout this whole thing, actually, this is the most important thing to realize. I think especially in your 20s, you know, sometimes the best relationships are those that could crush you the deepest because you care about them so much. You know that feeling when you look at somebody and you're like, I really hope you don't hurt me, but this could really hurt me. I think you kind of owe it to yourself to bed on that relationship.
Because even if it doesn't work out, at least you felt how deeply you could go. Even if people make mistakes, at least you experience true repair. At least you could kind of see how much love you truly have to give. I can totally understand if you don't agree with this. But I think so often we use playing it safe as an excuse to actually be avoidant. You could get hurt here. No amount of protective mechanisms or behavior. behaviors, no amount of withdrawing or moving closer is going to stop somebody from breaking your
heart if the relationship wasn't going to work in the first place. But continuing to adopt those behaviours, thinking they're going to protect you, thinking they're going to save you, is most certainly going to break your heart more because it's going to rule out all of these people who could have given you so many amazing experiences and could have given you so much. So when you look at the other person across from you and you acknowledge this could really hurt me, is this the person that you'd be willing to do that for? That's just like the question you have to get to the point of answering at the end of the day. And then you have to trust that they won't. You have to trust that if you put in the steps to be different, they will also do that. If you give somebody space,
if you ask somebody to come in further, they are going to be committed to it and the outcome for both of you is worth it. Because people do change out of this. People do find wonderful, healthy marriages and long-time relationships having come into love and having come into dating with this dynamic. Okay, we are going to take one final tiny break here before we discuss. I think the final big question of the day, I don't know if you guys are asking this, but it's definitely one that me and my friends have spoken about, which is, is it worth it your 20s. Is this kind of relationship and the commitment that you need for this kind of relationship something that you should be doing during this decade?
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's.
Correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
And rule two, never mess. with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserved. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
As I said, a controversial question to finish us off for today, a question I don't actually know the answer to, but I thought it could stir up some thoughts. Is this dynamic worth it in your 20s, especially maybe in your early 20s? What I kind of mean by this question is, and what I mean by this dilemma is that when you're in your early 20s when you're in your 20s, there is this narrative that the world is full of opportunities for love. The world is wide. The world is open to you. There are so many fish in the sea. Should you be spending time in relationships that ask you to change and to do so much for the other person? Is it worth working through this with somebody or should you cut your losses
and find a distancer? Find a pursuer who more matches your style. What I think is that sometimes we confuse discomfort in a relationship with pure misalignment. Relationships are always going to have their problem. Maybe this is just your problem. The pursuer distance the dynamic is uncomfortable. It activates you. It brings up old wounds. It exposes your attachment system in ways that feel almost embarrassing.
It's not embarrassing. That's just the way it feels. But discomfort alone isn't the reason or a reason to not try. sometimes discomfort especially in your 20s is data. Personally, I think this decade, it's not just for collecting experiences, it's also for collecting awareness. That is why even if this relationship with the distancer, with the pursuer, doesn't last, it is still worth its weight in lessons.
If you notice that you consistently choose emotionally unavailable people, that's not random. If you notice that you feel bored when somebody is consistent and is safe, that's not random. If you panic the moment somebody gets close or somebody gets a little bit of space, that is not random. These are patterns that the research shows us will be repeated again and again in life in your 20s until consciously examined. Because patterns don't dissolve just because the person you're in a relationship with changes. What I mean by that is that if you leave every time the pursuer distance or dynamic gets activated, you're probably just going to find yourself in another pursuer. distance a dynamic. You may feel temporarily relieved that you got out of that situation,
but this is your blueprint. You're going to find a very similar individual attractive very, very soon. The dance just starts with somebody new. That is what so many longitudinal attachment studies have shown us. You know, our internal models for relationships are remarkably stable unless they are actively worked on. And I'm not saying fixed. I'm not saying cured, but brought into awareness. So I think as a pursuer in your 20s, it is worth asking yourself, why am I like this? Why is this showing up in all of my relationships? And is there somebody I feel safe enough to tackle that with?
And as a distance, it's worth asking, why does closeness feel so engulfing? Why does needing to be pursued rather than pursuing feel like a connection? Why do I feel attracted when there is uncertainty and when there is certainty I lose interest? Like, this is worth exploring whether the person you explore it with ends up being the one or not. You know, I know people won't agree with that, but I just think your 20s are the safest time to confront this and to really go deep in a relationship like this if the other person is somebody you really care about. because the stakes are emotionally high, yes, but logistically lower. Especially in your early 20s, you might not share children, you might not share mortgages,
definitely don't share decades in decades of shared history and family. So you have flexibility, you have time, you have room to experiment, you have time to repair, working through a dynamic with somebody who is willing to self-reflect is going to be, what I think would be transformative. Again, the relationship might not last forever. There is no promise of that. Remember, we made a promise to each other that we have to be okay with getting hurt, but because you have the opportunity to learn, to learn what it's maybe like,
to not always play the same role in a relationship, and to not always be that same hurt individual who enters every relationship looking for something that no matter what the other person cannot give you, because you're either looking in the wrong places or searching for it in people who aren't willing to change. That being said, this is not a blanket endorsement to stay in every relationship that triggers you. There is a difference between a dynamic that is two self-aware people trying to grow and a dynamic that is one person refusing to take responsibility. Sometimes, let's be real, someone isn't a distancer. They just don't like you that much.
It's a hard pill to swallow, but it's true. And trying to label them into wanting to work on their behavior, trying to be like, don't you see? Like, you're a distancer. That's why this isn't working. It's not going to work if they genuinely don't care. Same thing with a pursuer. Sometimes they're not a pursuer.
Sometimes they just genuinely don't have boundaries and don't have respect for you. I think through all this discussion, this is definitely where I want to leave things. be able to identify what is a pattern, what is a wound, and what is just a genuine lack of interest. If someone is dismissive of your emotional bids, if you never get in what you, if you never get out what you give, if you never feel comfortable enough to say, I want to address this, this isn't working, I don't like how this is going, this person isn't it? And again,
it's not about the role you guys play in a relationship. It's not about what you're going. It's not about what dynamic you are falling into, it's just because you guys are not right for each other. And it's just because this other person isn't emotionally safe enough to work through a complicated situation with you. And love is complicated. Relationships are complicated and hard. And half of why they are beautiful, I think, in our 20s beyond, is because somebody else is like, yeah, okay, I'm committed to doing that with you, whatever the outcome. So if they're not it's never going to be as good as you want it to be. And it's definitely your sign to call it quits. So with all of that in mind, a final summary, the Pursue a Distance of Relationship Dynamic,
unbelievably prevalent, by the way, even over the course of researching this episode, not that I seek all of my examples from my friends and family, but it's definitely apparent in past relationships of mine and in people that I see around me. Once you start noticing it, you cannot stop noticing it. We do all typically fall one way, not completely one way or not to an extreme, but whether we are a pursuer, whether we are a distancer, comes down to attachment, comes down to nervous system regulation amongst a bunch of other things. That doesn't mean you won't find love. It doesn't mean all your relationships are doomed. With the right person, you will grow. You will love each other or find a connection that is,
so incredibly deep if the other person is committed to it, even if it takes a while. So that is the message I want to leave on. If you have made it this far and you are listening on Spotify, let me know, are you a distancer or are you a pursuer? Or are you somewhere in the middle? Which role do you find yourself relating to more? Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and that you maybe have watched an episode on Netflix if you are listening in the US or Canada. We actually recently got a new studio and it is very, very cool and a real vibe. So if you want to check that out and see behind the scenes of where I'm recording from right now, you can go and watch that over there. We also have a substack. If you want to read
our transcripts instead of listen to them in podcast form. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Thank you for tuning in. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts.
or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
Trust me, babe, on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I got you. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you give your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite
therapist and host, Keir Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to LoveTraft podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.